the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi today's lesson will complete our
first excursion into the subject of
linear algebra for the sake of linear
algebra and next time we will turn our
attention to applications of linear
algebra linear equations and the like
two applications towards functions of
several variables in the cases where the
functions are not necessarily linear now
you may recall that we concluded our
last lesson on the note of talking about
inverse matrices pointing out that an
inverse matrix existed provided that the
determinant of the coefficients making
up to make the determinant of the
entries making up the matrix was not 0
otherwise the inverse matrix didn't
exist but that we then said once we know
this how do we actually construct the
inverse matrix and what I hope to do in
today's lesson is to show you a rather
elegant manner inverting a matrix and at
the same time to point out several other
consequences that will be helpful in our
study of calculus of several variables
in other contexts as we proceed at any
rate today's lesson is called quite
simply inverting a matrix and to start
with a specific example in front of us
let's invert the matrix a-inverse where
a is the matrix whose entries are 1 1 1
2 3 4 3 4 6 keep in mind
among the various ways of motivating
matrix algebra we chose as our
particular illustration the coding
system of the matrix representing the
coefficients in a system of M equations
with n unknowns in this particular case
of a 3x3 matrix we view the matrix a as
coding the system of three linear
equations and three unknowns given by
system 1 I call that equation 1 we have
the system of three equations and three
unknowns by the way observe that this
looks very much like a problem that we
tackled in high school except for one
very small change in high school you may
remember that we tackled equations of
the form like this provided
that the wise were replaced by constants
in other words we weren't used to
thinking of linear systems of equations
in terms of functions this way but we
weren't used to thinking of things like
X 1 plus X 2 plus X 3 equals to 2 y 1
plus 3 X 2 plus 4 x 3 equals 9 3 X 1
plus 4 X 2 plus 6 X 3 equals 13 and then
the question was to solve specifically
for X 1 X 2 and X 3 right now the only
difference we're making now is that
we're not going to specify what y1 y2
and y3 are we'll mention the
relationship between our problem and the
high school one later in the lecture but
what we are saying is this we would like
in general given these three equations
and three unknowns this system of linear
equations we would like to be able to
solve for the X's in terms of the Y's
and that is what I'm going to show you
is identified with inverting the matrix
what I hope to show you as we go along
is that if the matrix a represents these
coefficients assuming that we find the
technique whereby we can express
uniquely for the X's in terms of the Y's
the coefficients that Express the X's as
linear combinations of the Y's those
coefficients involving the Y's will turn
out to be a inverse but we'll talk about
that more later I simply want to tell
you that now so to have a head start
into what my plan of attack is going to
be first of all let me mention a method
which you may have seen previously in
school but a very effective method for
systematizing are solving systems of
equations linear equations in a way that
works very very systematically the idea
is something like this we know that if
we replace one equation well split this
way
if we add equals to equals the results
are equal if we multiply equals by
equals the results are equal etc
consequently given a system of equations
like this we know that if we replace one
of the equations by that equation plus a
multiple of any other equation you see
if we add two equations together things
of this type where as we change the
system we don't change
the solutions to the system in other
words there are devices whereby we can
systematically replace the given system
of equations hopefully by simpler
systems of equations where the simpler
system of equations has the same set of
solutions as the original system and the
method that I'm thinking live is called
diagonalization for example what we
often say is something like this we say
look at wouldn't it be nice to get a
system in which x1 appears only in the
first equation and one way of doing that
notice is we observe that in the second
equation we have 2x1 in the first
equation we have x1 if we were to
subtract twice twice the first equation
from the second equation and use that
for our new second equation notice that
the new second equation would have no x1
per minute because 2 X 1 minus 2 X 1 is
0 similarly since the leading term in
the third equation is 3 x1 we observe
that if we were to subtract 3 times the
first equation from the third the
resulting third equation would have no
x1 3 minute so the new system would have
x1 in the first equation and no place
else similarly we could move over now to
our new second equation and then
eliminate x2 from every equation by but
the second by subtracting off the
appropriate multiple of the second
equation now what I'm going to do here
is that since it gets kind of messy
working with the Y ones y2 and y3 is and
it stretches out all over the place let
me invent a new type of coding system I
will take these three equations and
three unknowns and represent it by a 3
by 6 matrix as follows I will start off
with the following coding system I will
use place value these the first three
columns will represent X 1 X 2 X 3
respectively the next three columns will
represent y1 y2 and y3 respectively
assume an equal sign divides this and
this will simply be a coding device for
reading what x1 plus x2 plus x3 equals
y1 2x1 plus 3x2 plus 4 X 3 equals
by 2 3 X 1 plus 4 X 2 plus 6 X 3 equals
y 3 notice why I say y 3 it's 0 y 1 plus
0 Y 2 plus 1 Y 3 which of course is y 3
notice also that the left side of this 3
by 6 matrix is precisely the matrix a
that we're investigating back here all
right I just want that for future
reference now let me go through this
procedure what I will now do is subtract
twice the first equation from the second
and make that my new second one and I
will subtract three times the first
equation from the third to give me my
new third equation which means in terms
of the matrix notation that I am
replacing the second row of this matrix
by the second row minus twice the first
row I'm replacing the third row by the
third row minus three times the first
row I now wind up with this particular 3
by 6 matrix right again just by brief
review what this matrix system tells me
for example is among other things that X
2 plus 2 X 3 is minus 2 y 1 plus y 2 you
see now I have a coding system here but
the right-hand side allows me to check
how I got the resulting matrix on the
left-hand side it tells me how the Y's
had to be combined to give me this
combination of the X's at any rate I now
want to eliminate one every place in the
second column except in the second row
so looking at this matrix now what I
will do is I will replace the first row
by the first minus the second C 1 minus
1 is 0 so my new first row will have a 0
here I will then replace the third row
by the third minus the second again
meaning what
that my new third row will have a 0 here
leaving the details for you to check for
yourself the result in 3 by 6 matrix now
looks like this by the way again notice
what this tells me among other things
this tells me that X 3 is minus y1 minus
y2 plus y3 which somehow tells me that
the
x3 I essentially have to do what I can
find I can subtract the first equation
and the second equation from the the sum
of the first and second equation from
the third equation and that will give me
extreme you know by the way just as a
quick look over here just to show you
how nice this technique is maybe
somebody who had been very quick could
have looked at this system of equations
and said you know if I add the first two
equations this will give me a 3 X 1 this
will give me a 4 X 2 and therefore if I
subtract that from the third equation
the X 1 term and the X 2 term will drop
out etc the thing I want to point out is
that this matrix system makes geniuses
out of all of us that we do not have to
be able to see these intricacies to be
able to get down to a stage like this by
the way again what this tells me is I
now have a simpler method for solving
this original system of equations namely
I can now solve this system of equations
the one that's coded by this and the
solutions of this equation will be the
same set as the solutions to my original
equation at any rate continuing this
diagonalization method still more what I
now do is I try to replace what in the
third column I try to get zeros
everywhere except in the third row and
to put that in still other words I guess
in the language of matrices what I'm
going to try to do is get what the 3 by
3 identity matrix to make up the first
half over here that's in terms of the
matrix language now again to show you
quickly what I'm trying to do here I'm
simply going to do what over here I'm
going to replace the first equation by
the first the first row by the first
plus the third I'm going to replace the
second row by the second row minus twice
the third I now wind up with this
particular matrix I claim that the right
half C the left half of this matrix is
the identity matrix I claim that the
left half is the identity matrix I claim
the right half is a inverse alright
that's what my claim is and by the way
let's see
why I say that what system of equations
does a inverse code just read what this
says it says X 1 is equal to 2 y 1 minus
2 y 2 plus y 3 X 2 is equal to Y 2 minus
2 y 3 and X 3 is minus y 1 minus y 2
plus y 3 in other words a inverse codes
this particular system let's call that
system 2 how a system 2 and what we call
system 1 related the relationship was
that system 1 expressed the Y's in terms
of the X's system 2 shows what it would
look like if the X's were expressed in
terms of the Y's and so what we have
done in the language of whatever you
want to call it but what we've done is
we've inverted the role of the variables
that we styled with the Y's given in
terms of the X's we now have the x's
expressed in terms of the Y's now since
you may want to see this more in matrix
language let me show you another way of
seeing the same result that doesn't that
uses the word inverse in the way we're
used to seeing inverse matrix defined in
terms of our present course the matrix
algebra interpretation is simply this
let's sweep let's rewrite system 1
search you can see it here and the
interesting point is the following
think of these wise as fall as forming a
column vector or column matrix whichever
way you want to read this thing in other
words I am going to view this as being
the matrix which has three rows and one
column namely the matrix y 1 y 2 y 3 I
am now going to take the matrix of
coefficients here which as we recall is
the matrix a but that's what 1 1 1 2 3 4
3 4 6 and I am now going to write X 1 X
2 X 3 as a column vector rather than as
a row vector and in turn I can think of
that as being a column matrix again 3 by
1 matrix three rows one column now what
I claim is that this system of three
equal three equations in three unknowns
so to speak is equivalent to the single
matrix equation given by this in fact to
make this easier to read let's let
capital y denote the column matrix y1 y2
y3 let's let capital X denote the column
matrix x1 x2 x3 and capital a is before
the original matrix and my claim is that
the system of three equations and three
unknowns is represented by the single
matrix equation Capital y equals a times
capital X and just to show you by way of
a very quick review why this is the case
remember
how we multiply two matrices to find the
term in the first row first column we
multiply the first row of the first by
the first column of the second and since
that's supposed to equal this matrix and
since matrices are equal only if they're
equal entry by into entry it means that
this product must equal y1 notice what
that says it says x1 plus x2 plus x3
equals y1 similarly 2 times x1 plus 3
times x2 plus 4 times x3 is going to
have to equal Y 2 and similarly 3 times
x1 plus 4 times x2 plus 6 times x3 is
going to have to equal y3 and that's
precisely the original system of
equations that we began with now notice
that this expresses the matrix Y as
something times the matrix X if a
inverse exists multiply both sides of
this matrix equation by a inverse on the
left hand side we get a inverse Y on the
right hand side a inverse times ax by
associativity is a inverse a times X a
inverse times a is the identity matrix
the identity matrix doesn't change the
given matrix that it's multiplying so we
have that a inverse Y is just X and
notice that the role of a inverse is
again just as mentioned above that what
we've done is we have started with Y
given as a matrix times X we now have X
expressed as a matrix times y in fact if
you now take
the matrix that we call a inverse
originally and carry out this operation
we will see that this is precisely what
does happen this is what the
identification is in other words the
system of equations is identifiable with
a single matrix equation and that matrix
equation can be inverted meaning we can
solve for X in terms of Y if and only if
a inverse exists there is still a third
interpretation and interpretation that
goes back to the idea of mappings and
that is we can think of the original
system 1 as map as a mapping that
carries three-dimensional space into
three-dimensional space how is it
carries three-dimensional space into
three-dimensional space well it can we
view it as carrying the three topo X 1 X
2 X 3 into the three top of y1 y2 y3
okay by the system of equations defined
by system 1 and to show you what I mean
but I have more detail suppose I pick X
1 to be 1 X 2 to be 1 X 3 to be 1 just
for the sake of argument suppose I
picked that X 1 X 2 X 3 or all 1
what this means is looking come back to
the original system replace X 1 X 2 and
X 3 by 1 if we do that we see that y 1
is 3 y 2 is 9 and y 3 is 13 therefore we
would say what that f bar maps 1 1 1
into 3 9 13 by the way you're going to
notice this sooner or later that this
bothered me when I first did this is
just a little aside you may have noticed
that when I was arbitrarily writing down
numbers to pick for y1 y2 and y3 when we
first died at the beginning of the
lecture I said why don't we let Y 1 B 2
y 2 B 9 and y 3 beats 13 and it looks
almost like I made a mistake and meant
to get to 9 13 back again I got 3 9 13
notice that to get to 9 13 I wouldn't
have I couldn't pick X 1 X 2 and X 3 all
to be 1 but I could pick X 1 to be minus
1 X 2 to be 1
X
3 2 b2 and then what that says is if I
let x1 be minus 1 X to be plus 1 and x3
be 3 it says that under those conditions
y1 would have been 2 y2 would have been
9 and y3 would have been 13 course the
question that you not now may ask which
I hope gives you some sort of a cross
reference to go by is how did I know see
starting with 1 1 1 it seemed very easy
to find the image 3 9 13 now I say
starting with the image how do I find
that this is what I would mapped into 2
9 13 how did I know see here it was easy
I started with the input X bar but here
I'm starting with the output and I'm
trying to find the input how did I find
minus 1 1 2 that fast and the answer is
that's precisely where the role of the
inverse matrix comes in you see going
back to what we did just a little while
ago when we inverted system one to get
system 2 what did we do we showed how to
find X 1 X 2 X 3
once y1 y2 and y3 were given so all I
had to do here was knowing that I wanted
Y want to be 2 right through to be 9 and
y3 to be 13 I just shoved those values
in here and saw what x1 x2 and x3 word
in fact this is why working with the Y's
is an improvement over what the high
school system was of picking the wives
to be constant you see once I've done
this you see I can find what x1 x2 x3
look like in terms of the Y's all in one
shot regardless of what values of y
somebody is going to give me to play
around with later on but returning now
to our immediate problem notice all I'm
saying is is that when I'm given a
system of n equations and linear
equations and unknowns even n equations
and unknowns in this case we had three
linear equations and three unknowns I
can view that in a very natural way as a
mapping from three dimensional space
into three dimensional space notice that
the matrix of coefficients a and the
mapping F bar and our coin a word here
could I don't know
exactly how I want you to see this but
they're identifiable they're essentially
equivalent
notice that given X bar I want to apply
f bar to that to find y bar
notice that in terms of our matrix
language we show that after all capital
y the matrix capital y which had entries
y 1 y 2 y 3 is just a different numeral
for writing this vector this is a 3 this
is a 3 typo this is the same three tuple
written as they call them rather than as
a row X bar is a three tuple but capital
X is that same three tuple written as a
column vector rather than as a row
vector but notice that the
identification that if Y bar is f bar of
X bar that says the same information as
saying that Capital y is the matrix a
times capital X these convey equivalent
pieces of information and still other
words notice that in finding the images
of f bar here and inverting the images I
use precisely the same device that I
used in the system without giving the
mapping interpretation in other words
these do convey the same information so
that from a major point of view we can
identify the matrix a with the mapping F
bar and you see what this means is that
if we can identify a with F bar we
should be able to identify a inverse
with the inverse function so that's the
other way we've used the word inverse as
an inverse function the existence of a
inverse is equivalent to the existence
of f bar inverse and by the way we
showed that you see using the system of
equations that we started with we showed
that if X 1 is -1 X 2 is 1 and X 3 is 2
that y 1 would be 2 y 2 would be 9 and y
3 would be 13 we also showed that if we
started with y 1 equals 2 y 2 equals 9
and y 3 equals 13
then the X's had to be given by minus 1
1 and 2 in terms of the mapping what
we're saying is not only does minus 1 1
2
map into 2 9 13 but 2 9 13 can only be
obtained from the three top of -1 1 2
you see in essence in this particular
case the existence of a inverse showed
that F powers aren't 2 we could get any
three top what we wanted and it was also
1 2 1 the important point in terms of
our theory of matrices is that since f
bar inverse need not exist for a given F
Abe inverse need not exist for a given
matrix a in other words if we're
identifying the matrix with the function
if the inverse function doesn't exist
the inverse matrix doesn't exist in
other words not all matrices are
invertible and let's emphasize that we
knew that from before but let's
emphasize this now in terms of our
structure namely let's take a new
example let's try to invert a matrix
which doesn't have an inverse obviously
if I try to do that I should fail
dismally and let's see how that does
work out let me take the matrix a to be
1 1 1 2 3 4 3 4 5 I deliberately call
this a again even though we've used a
before I've deliberately made this a
look very much like the a we work with
before if you compare this with our
original a the only difference is I now
have a 5 here rather than a 6 I simply
want to show you how a subtle change can
affect the existence of an inverse again
by way of very quick review before we go
any further notice that this matrix
codes what system of equations this
particular system of equations and so if
you don't see any hanky-panky going on
here and wondering why I knew that
something was going to go wrong here let
me show you in advance why I can't
invert this then show you how our matrix
coding system gives us the same
information even if we weren't bright
enough to see this just for the sake of
argument suppose I had a keen enough eye
to observe right away that if I added
the first two equations I would get that
Y 1 plus y 2 is what 3 X 1 plus 4
two plus 5x3 all right and now I look at
this result
compare that with my third equation
where the right-hand sides are identical
and conclude from this that this is not
really three equations with three
unknowns this is really two equations
with three unknowns because this
equation here is either redundant or
incompatible meaning notice that these
two facts tell me that Y 1 plus y 2 has
to equal Y 3 to show you what I mean by
that let me pick specific values for y1
y2 and y3 in which y3 is not equal to y1
plus y2 and to keep this as close to the
problem that we were working with
originally let me pick y1 to be 2 y 2 to
be nine and y3 to be 13
notice that this system of equations
cannot possibly have a solution now this
system of equations here cannot possibly
have a solution because if it had a
solution that would imply what that if I
add these two equations it would say
that 3 X 1 plus 4 X 2 plus 5 X 3 equals
11 if I add these two equations that
would say it also has to equal 13 and
since 11 is equal to 13 I have to
correct a mistake I made in an earlier
lecture it's for large values of 11 that
11 is equal to 13 but other than that 11
is unequal to 13 this means that it's
impossible to find solutions to this
equation but we'll come back to that in
a little while the main point and will
also emphasize this in the exercises but
the main point now is to show how we
could have obtained this information by
our matrix coding system and we do
exactly the same thing as we did before
we take this matrix and we augment it by
the 3 by 3 identity matrix remember
again where our coding system says is
that the first three columns represent
the X's the next three the Y's for
example this says X 1 plus X 2 plus X 3
equals y 1 etc we now go through what I
call the role reducing operations which
means what we're going to replace Row
by the RO plus or minus a suitable
multiple of another row so that we do
what we wind up with a one eventually
only here and zeros elsewhere a one here
zeroes here or one here and zeros here
if we can do that let's see what happens
here what I'm going to do of course is
I'm going to replace the second row here
by the second minus twice the first I'll
replace the third row by the third minus
three times the first I now wind up with
this equivalent matrix that this matrix
codes the same system of equations as
the original matrix now I'm going to
replace the first row by the first row
minus the second I will replace the
third row by the third row minus the
second and since I already have a 1 in
here I will leave the second row intact
and if I do that I now wind up with this
3 by 6 matrix and now a very interesting
thing has happened
maybe alarming maybe unhappy but
nonetheless interesting I observe that
on the left hand side of my 3 by 6
matrix here I have a row consisting
entirely of zeros that in row reducing
this I have lost any chance of getting a
1 over here because this whole row has
dropped out see one of two things had to
happen when I wrote when I finished I
would have had the identity matrix here
or else I would have had in this left
hand half I would have had at least one
row of zeros in this case I got the one
row of zeros let's translate what this
thing says it says X 1 minus X 3 is 3 y
1 minus y 2 X 2 plus 2 X 3 is minus 2 y
1 plus y 2 and it also says that what 0
X 1 plus 0 X 2 plus 0 X 3 in other words
0 is equal to minus y 1 minus y 2 plus y
3 and let's write that to emphasize this
you see what we really have from the
first two equations is this system here
two equations but in three unknowns X 1
X 2 X 3 we're assuming that the Y's
unknowns now the the third piece of
information I've written in an
accentuated form
to emphasize the fact that the third
equation tells us under what conditions
we're in trouble as far as the choice of
the Y's are concerned namely what this
tells us is that if minus y 1 minus y 2
plus y 3 has to be 0 to be able to solve
this system at all that's the same as
saying of course that y 3 is y 1 plus y
2 so the first thing we know is that
unless y 3 equals y 1 plus y 2 we cannot
express the X's in terms of the Y's why
can't we express them the system is
incompatible
that's exactly by the way what we
observe over here only now we don't have
to be that bright to notice that see
here we had two astutely observed that
the third equation was the sum of the
first two matrix coding system told us
right away that what went wrong here
was that y 3 equals y 1 plus y 2 so
unless y 3 equals y 1 plus y 2 we cannot
express the X's in terms of the Y's the
second thing that goes wrong is that
even if y 3 equals y 1 plus y 2 then for
example we still can't express the X's
in terms of the Y's because I say for
example here because I could have picked
any of the X's as far as that's
concerned but for example X 3 is
independent of y 1 and y 2 I add and Y 3
in parentheses here because notice in
the second case y 3 is not independent
of y 1 and y 2 y 3 is equal to y 1 plus
y 2 so it's automatically specified as
soon as I know y 1 and y 2 but here's
what I'm saying if I now take this with
this result here and come back to this
system of equations assuming that that y
1 plus y 2 is y 3 so like I now have
this constraint here met notice that I
can pick X 3 completely at random
independently of what the values of y1
and y2 are pick X 3 completely at random
and solve for x1 and x2 in other words I
have a degree of freedom here the the
X's are not completely determined by the
Y's one of the X's can be so chosen at
random it just floats around ok so you
see what goes wrong here
for the point of view of inverting the
equations if the constraint meaning y 3
equals y 1 plus y 2 is not met you can't
pop invert at all the system is
incompatible if the constraint is met
the X's aren't completely determined by
the Y's you can pick one of the X's at
random and then solve for the remaining
two now what does this mean in terms of
our function interpretation and I think
you may enjoy this because I think it
will show things very nicely what it
means for example is this suppose I now
look at the mapping that's defined by
the system of equations that we were
just talking about notice that what
we're saying is that unless y 3 equals y
1 plus y 2 there's no hope of finding
X's that solve that particular equation
in other words if it turns out given
this mapping that Y bar is 1 1 3 then
there is no X bar such that f bar of x
bar is equal to Y bar because 3 is
unequal to 1 plus 1 you see again what
we're saying in terms of the mapping is
to get a solution to get a solution the
Y's have to be no longer arbitrary but
chosen to satisfy a specific constraint
and in the system of equations 3 that we
dealt with in this case that constraint
was y 3 equals y 1 plus y 2 in other
words what this means in terms of the
mapping is an f bar is not onto C notice
the equation wasn't invertible a inverse
didn't exist therefore f bar inverse
shouldn't exist and for f bar inverse
not to exist it's sufficient that f bar
be either not on 2 or else not
one-to-one and we've now shown that f
bar is not on - because nothing maps
into 1 1 3 we can go one step further
and show that even if the constraint is
met suppose we pick a y bar where y 3 is
equal to y1 plus y2 for example 1 1 - C
2 is equal to 1 plus 1 then the system
of equations that we had before applies
what was that system of equations that
we had before it was x1 minus x3
equals 3 y 1 minus y 2 X 2 plus 2 X 3
equals -2 y 1 plus y 2 the third
equation wasn't taken an equation
it was the constraint that required that
y 3 equals y 1 plus y 2 so that's been
met so we now are down to what two
equations and three unknowns I now claim
that first of all let's take a look and
see what happens over here in this case
y 1 is 1 y 2 is 1 so X 1 minus X 3 is
simply 2 X 2 plus 2 X 3 is simply minus
1 I can now pick X 3 at random and solve
for X 1 and X 2 in terms of that namely
what X 1 is simply X 3 plus 2 and X 2 is
minus 2 X 3 minus 1 in other words what
this tells me is that a whole bunch of
vectors are mapped into 1 1 2 a whole
bunch of three tuples if you want use
the word 3 topple rather than vector I
mapped into 1 1 2 by F bar how are those
vectors chosen well you can pick the
third component at random in which case
the first component X 1 is simply X 3
plus 2 and the second component X 2 is
simply minus 2 X 3 minus 1 where the X 3
is the value that you chose here since
there are infinitely many ways of
choosing X 3 there are infinitely many
three tuples that map into 1 1 2 in
particular f bar is not one-to-one
either
which means in terms of a picture and in
fact let me let's see how we can work
this very comfortably why not pick X 3
to be 0 for a start if we pick X 3 to be
0
notice that this three tuple becomes 2
minus 1 0 so 2 minus 1 0 2 minus 1 0
maps into 1 1 2 if we pick X 3 to be say
1 this becomes 3 minus 3 1 so for
example 3 minus 3 1 also maps into 1 1 2
so that's the demonstration that f bar
is not one-to-one and the fact that
nothing maps into 1 1 3
is the indication that f bar is not on -
by the way by choosing a
three-dimensional space we can interpret
this result geometrically now what I'm
going to do here is really optional from
your point of view if you don't like
studies of three-dimensional space
ignore what I'm saying otherwise I don't
mean ignore it take it with a grain of
salt look it over really is not crucial
to understanding abstractly what's going
on but I thought a visual example like
this might be helpful notice that when
you're mapping III into III you're
mapping three-dimensional space into
three-dimensional space by the way
notice the end tuple notation here I
prefer to write the X 1 X 2 X 3 space
rather than the traditional X Y Z space
in other words f bar is mapping X 1 X 2
X 3 space into y1 y2 y3 space and what
we have shown so far is that without
particular choice of function under
consideration now the only way F bi Maps
something into anything is if that
anything has what property to it what
does the point y1 y2 y3 have to satisfy
in order that we can be sure that
something from the x1 x2 x3 plane space
maps into it and the constraint was what
that y 3 equals y1 plus y2 now this is a
good time to review our equation of
planes in three-dimensional space sure
we're used to talking about Z equals X
plus y but don't worry about that part
notationally y 3 equals y 1 plus y 2 is
the equation of a plane in fact what
plane is it instead of going into a long
harangue about this let me just find
three points that around this plane in
particular 0 0 0 satisfies this plane to
2 for C 2 plus 2 is 4 1 plus 3 is 4 so
three quick points I can pick off out of
the origin 2 2 4 1 3 4 these are three
points not on the same straight line
they determine the plane the image of f
bar is this particular plane in other
words f bar does not use up
of 3-space it in particular uses up this
one particular plane in particular let's
look at our point 1 1 2 what did we see
before mapped into 1 1 2 we saw that any
three tuple X 1 X 2 X 3 where we picked
X 3 at random whereupon X 1 had to be X
3 plus 2 X 2 has to be minus 2 X 3 minus
1 notice that this system of equations
defines a line you see think of X 3 as
being a parameter here if it bothers you
think of X 3 is being T and what you
have is that X 1 is T plus 2 X 2 is
minus 2 t minus 1 and X 3 is T that is
the parametric form of an equation for a
straight line you see notice you have
only one degree of freedom T and T
appears only linearly now look at to
find the actual straight line
geometrically all I have to do is find
two points on that line to relate this
with what we were doing last time you
know just previous to this notice that
two points that we know are on this line
are 2 minus 1 0 and 3 minus 3 1 let's
look at this graphically let's locate
the point 2 minus 1 0 3 minus 3 1 in the
x1 x2 x3 space draw the line that joins
those two points that line L has the
property that every single one of these
points on L map into the point 1 1 2 in
the y1 y2 y3 space in other words our
mapping in this case is neither one 2
one neuron true the entire image of this
3 dimensional space is a single plane
and given a point not in that plane
therefore nothing maps into that but
given a point in that plane an entire
line from the domain maps in there and I
simply point this out to you so that for
those of you who would like to have a
picture of what's happening I think this
is a very nice way of saying it the
reason I don't want to emphasize the
picture more is simply because we will
deal in the notes and the exercises with
system
of more than three equations and three
unknowns we will deal with linear
mapping say from i-5 in to e5 in which
case we can't draw the picture so the
picture is only a nice mental aid in
setting things up in the two by two case
or the three by three case but other
than that one has to rely on the
equivalent of the matrix system for
reducing these equations so let me
summarize then what our main aim was and
what we have accomplished leaving out
the motivations of everything for the
time being let me just summarize how we
invert a matrix provided that the matrix
inverse exists given the N by n matrix a
we form the N by 2 n matrix a mented by
the N by n identity matrix in other
words what matrix is it the left half is
a 1 up to a 1 n a n 1 a and then in
other words it's the matrix a and the
right half is just the N by n identity
matrix we then row reduce this remember
what I mean by row reduce subtracting
approp replacing rows by the row plus or
minus an appropriate multiple of another
row helping to get the identity matrix
to come over to the right hands to the
left hand side over here we row reduce
this matrix and then what we saw was
what we did in the 3 by 3 case we're now
doing it in the N by n case by the way
notice that if this throws you off
abstractly in the 3 by 3 case the
Augmented matrix that we formed had was
a 3 by 6 all we're saying is in the end
by n case you're tacking on side by side
to n by n matrices which makes the
resulting matrix n by 2n at any rate
what we do is we reduce this n by 2n
matrix
until one of two things happens and one
of the two must happen namely either the
left hand half this half contains at
least one row of zeros in which case a
inverse doesn't exist the other
alternative is that when we row reduce
the left-hand side does the left left
half in other words does become the
identity matrix in which case the right
half is a inverse that's all there is to
this mechanically you row reduced the
end by 2n matrix all right if the
left-hand side contains a row of zeros
there is no inverse to the given matrix
if it reduces to the identity matrix
then the right half is the inverse
matrix part two of our summary namely
what can we conclude if a inverse exists
in terms of matrix algebra if a inverse
exists we can solve in other words we
can invert the equation y equals a X to
conclude that x equals a inverse y and
finally in terms of mappings if we
define f bar from a sub n into e sub n f
bar is a mapping from n dimensional
space into n dimensional space defined
by this then f bar inverse exists if and
only if a inverse exists where a is the
matrix of coefficients over here and if
a inverse doesn't exist then f bar
inverse not only doesn't exist but f bar
itself is neither one-to-one nor on two
now admittedly today's lecture was a
little bit on the long side it was
though in a sense a single concept
hopefully with many interpretations it
is a very very crucial thing in many of
our investigations to do at least one of
two things one thing is going to be we
are going to want to know whether the
inverse of a matrix exists in certain
applications we will not care to know
what that inverse matrix is all we're
going to want to know is does it exist
in that case that's when it's sufficient
to compute the determinant of a matrix
namely for determinant is 0 it doesn't
exist if the determinant is not 0 the
inverse matrix does exist on other
occasions it will not be enough to know
that the inverse exists we will also
require that we be able to construct a
inverse from the given matrix a and that
in essence was the lesson that we were
trying to cover today starting with
next lesson we will apply these results
to systems of functions of several real
variables and until that time goodbye
funding for the publication
this video was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate